Tenemos cuatro triángulos representados aquí.
Nos dicen que los triángulos no están dibujados a
escala y nos preguntan cuáles de estos triángulos
son congruentes. Pausen este video y traten de
resolverlo por su cuenta. Muy bien, trabajemos
juntos. Parece que nos han dado dos ángulos
y un lado en cada uno de estos triángulos, o en
realidad casi en todos. En este triángulo IJH sólo
nos han dado dos ángulos. Lo que me gustaría hacer
es calcular el tercer ángulo, porque conocemos dos
ángulos del triángulo, y la suma de los ángulos de
un triángulo tiene que ser 180°. Y luego podemos
usar esa información tal vez con los lados que
nos dan para juzgar cuáles de estos triángulos
son congruentes. En primer lugar, ¿cuál será la
medida de este ángulo que tenemos aquí, la medida
del ángulo ACB? Pausen el video y traten de pensar
en esto. Bueno, una forma de pensar en esto es que
si llamamos x a la medida de ese ángulo, sabemos
que x + 36 + 82 tiene que ser igual a 180, y sólo
estamos poniendo aquí sus medidas en grados. Y
podríamos decir que x más, veamos, 36 + 82 = 118.
¿Lo hice bien? 6 + 2 son 8 y luego 3 + 8 son
11. Sí, está bien: x + 118 = 180; y luego,
si restamos 118 de ambos lados, vamos a obtener
que x = 180 - 118 = 62, así que esto es: x = 62,
este es un ángulo de 62°. Supongo que es otra
forma de pensar en esto; podríamos ponerlo todo
en términos de grados. Muy bien, ahora hagamos lo
mismo con este triángulo que tenemos aquí. Bueno,
este tiene un ángulo de 82° y un ángulo de
62°, como este triángulo que tenemos aquí.
Entonces sabemos que el tercer ángulo debe ser de
36°, 36° porque conocemos el de 82° y el de 62,
si necesitamos llegar a 180 este tiene que ser
de 36°. Lo acabamos de calcular en el primer
triángulo que tenemos aquí. Ahora, si revisamos
este triángulo, tenemos 36° y 59°. Este triángulo
definitivamente tiene diferentes ángulos.
Calculemos cuánto debería medir este ángulo. Así
que si le llamamos y a este ángulo: y + 36 + 59
= 180, y estamos pensando en términos de grados,
así que y más, esto va a ser igual a 95 = 180. ¿Lo
hice bien? Sí, 80 + 15 sí es igual a 95; y luego
si restamos 95 de ambos lados, ¿qué nos queda?, y
es igual a 85°, de modo que este ángulo es igual
a 85°. Y luego veamos este último triángulo que
tenemos aquí. Tenemos un ángulo que mide 36, otro
que mide 59, entonces, por la misma lógica, este
de aquí tiene que ser de 85°. Preguntémonos ahora
que sabemos un poco más sobre estos triángulos
¿cuáles deberían ser congruentes? Podríamos estar
tentados a mirar estos dos triángulos inferiores
y decir que todos sus ángulos son iguales: tenemos
ángulo, ángulo, ángulo y ángulo, ángulo, ángulo.
Bueno, serían triángulos similares. Si tienes tres
ángulos que son iguales definitivamente tienes
triángulos similares, pero no tenemos información
de las longitudes del triángulo IJH, necesitamos
conocer al menos la longitud de uno de los lados
para incluso considerar pensar en congruencia, de
modo que no podemos llegar a ninguna conclusión
de que el triángulo IJH y el triángulo LMK sean
congruentes entre sí. Ahora echemos un vistazo
a estos triángulos de aquí arriba. Sabemos que
todos sus ángulos son iguales, así que podríamos
aplicar ángulo, lado, ángulo: 36°, longitud 6,
82°; 36°, longitud 6, 82°, así que por ángulo,
lado, ángulo, sabemos que el triángulo ABC
sin duda es congruente con el triángulo FDE.